let n be a positive integer and let this
integral n equal the integral of log x
to the power of n dx so this is
obviously a pretty crucial result just
over here
that integral there we're going to use
that all right prove that i n equals and
then you've got this result here now
when you look at this closely
you can see i hope that this has come
from integration by parts it's got that
kind of telltale sign right of you've
got this here oopsy daisy you've got
this here at the front which is being
integrated and then you take away
another integral which is what happens
when you do integration by parts
part two is going to say we'll use that
to find out this and essentially this
recurrence relation or this reduction
formula that we're going to prove in
part one will allow us to see this this
power here we can go from that to climb
down to a 2 down to a 1 and then down to
a 0 or in reverse order as you're about
to see
okay so let's use integration by parts
this is question one
c
oops is he
not use a laser pointer it's not very
helpful part t let's form this integral
so i've got i n equals the integral of
log x the paraben
d
x all right now i want to think about
okay for part one
what is the appropriate u and what is
the appropriate dv now this is one of
those cases where um it looks like a
product log x times you know itself a
number of times but the most easy way to
break this apart is actually just to
treat this entire thing as u because if
i then say there's a one let's just
sneak this in here
there's a 1 hanging in there if i make
that the dv then it's very easy to
integrate and it will introduce the
x term that you can see right here right
this is going to be the
vdu that you can see this is this x will
be the v right so therefore i'm going to
write out here let's designate u as my
as the other part of the integrand the
log part log x to the power of n
and that gives me a d u on dx which is
equal to uh this is just chain rule
isn't it so bring that power out the
front log x reduce the power by one and
then multiply by the inside derivative
which in this case is one over x so
there's my u and d u let's now do dv
and v so i said that i was going to
sneak in a 1 there which means that when
i integrate up i'm going to just get x
so this is going to be part of my
yeah my my uv result that you can see in
there so i'm ready to do my integration
by parts now i can say therefore i n
equals
okay here comes u v so x log x to the n
out the front which is promising because
that's what we needed back over here in
the question
and then what i'm what am i subtracting
well i'm going to subtract you know how
this works it's going to be v times d u
but notice what's going on here
you can see this x that we've introduced
in the v is going to cancel with this 1
over x that we introduced in the d u so
i need to show this by the way because
this is a
prove that question so even though i'm
noticing that i'm still going to write
here in the next line it's going to be
the integral of x and then everything
here comes along for the right
soup
with respect to x
but then now that i've written that i
can go cancel cancel
and if you look at this closely you can
see
this uh log x to the n minus 1 looks
just like i to the i n not i to the n i
sub n
except the power is different so that's
the i n minus one i've climbed down and
then this n out here can come
it's just a constant coefficient so i
can remove it from the integral
altogether so that gives me x
log x the power of n minus don't skip
anything integral of log x to the n
minus 1 dx which is equal to
and this is the result that i was trying
to prove n
i to the n minus 1 as required
okay
excellent so then i'm now asked to use
this right it says hence find the exact
value of this particular integral now
you can see that the particular power
that they've handed to us is
3 right
log x cubed so i'm going to need to go
from cube down to squared down to 1 down
to 0. okay now that's one way to do it
however even though you can do it
accurately and i'll show you what that
looks like in a second
it's actually fairly error prone to do
that and you'll see why once i make an
attempt at doing it okay
it's error prone because you sort of
overload your working memory so how can
we try and reduce the amount of working
memory that we're using
while doing this question well as i
write down part two what i'm going to do
is instead of writing the question and
sort of using that as my starting point
the integral from 1 to 2 of log x cubed
i'm actually going to start all the way
down from the bottom with the simplest
terms so instead of i you know log x
cubed i'm going to start with log x to
the 0. that's that's as simple as i can
do it's trivial in fact and then i'm
going to build from 0 up to 1 2 and 3
and that way i can simplify as i go
which reduces the working memory demands
and
avoids the cognitive overload that can
often happen so let's have a go at doing
this
i'm going to
start off with whoopsie daisy i zero so
by definition
it's going to be
in fact i'm going to do this from
1 to 2 because the question specifies so
i'm going to integrate from 1 to 2
log x
to the 0
dx okay so i'm being slightly flexible
there with my notation of
i 0 because
the i n that was introduced up here
doesn't have the boundaries there you
can see oops right there this is just an
indefinite integral here but i think
it's going to be okay for me to use it
in this fashion
so let's go ahead and start simplifying
this right this is the let's zoom in a
bit
there we go
integral from 1 to 2 of 1 with respect
to x because that's what happens when
you raise stuff to the power of 0.
last i checked the integral of 1 is just
x from one to two
top bound take away lower bound bam i've
got one so that's about as nice as it
gets for i zero suppose we shouldn't be
surprised because it is a basic term
let's go to i one okay so
from the earlier part of the question
part 1 we can say this is the x log x to
the power of whatever your value of n is
right so in this case it's going to be x
log x and it's log x to the power of 1.
so
it's log x now you might remember in
integration by parts when we use it when
you substitute through and if you have
boundaries that means this is actually
not just x log x as a random sort of um
you know with the variables intact but
it's actually just the x's are just
dummy variables this is a definite
integral right or it's the end product
of a definite integration process so
that's why you can see i've included
these boundaries in here
and then i'm going to be subtracting um
n times i n minus 1. right you can see
that result right there so the n in this
case is 1 the i n minus 1 in this case
is i
0 which thankfully i just evaluated so
therefore i can say let's now start
doing this right i can do my upper bound
take away my lower bound so that will be
2 log 2
take away 1 log 1. we'll return to that
in a second and then i'm going to
subtract 1 times 1 because that was i 0
which we just worked out we just
determined earlier
ok
that leaves me with 2 log 2 log 1 is
just 0 like what's the power that i
raise a number 2 to get 1 0
and then you've got that minus 1. so you
can see this term has vanished and that
minus 1 is just sort of tucked in there
okay i've built from successfully from
i0 to i1 let's just keep on going up the
ladder so this is going to be now i2
it's equal to all right now just be
careful going back to your occurrence
relation it's x log x to the power of n
my n is now 2. so therefore i'm going to
have
x
log x and that log x has been squared
you can see this log x is just the power
of 1 that's why i didn't need to write
it between 1 and 2 and then i'm going to
subtract in lots of the previous
i right so it's it's 2 lots of i 1
that's what i got in the previous line
so let's break the page there
now let's do let's see here i think i
need a square bracket again
here comes the upper bound so 2
log 2 squared take away and here comes
the lower bound 1
log 1
squared just be careful what you're
substituting into what you're putting 2s
into here so you're like is that power
there something i'm substituting it to
no it's part of the actual primitive
and then i'm going to subtract 2 lots of
i1 i know what i1 is i had it here from
the previous line so i'm going to
duplicate that don't forget it needs
some brackets okay
that's looking promising let's expand
this so i've got 2 outside of log 2
squared just like we had before this log
1 term is just 0. so it is
gone skis and then what i've got
trailing on the end here there's going
to be 4
log 2
and then there's a double negative here
so i'm going to add
2 all right
fantastic i've built up to i2 my last
one now is to do i3 and then i'm up to
this cube term right so i can say
i3
equals all right
one more time with feeling uh x log x
this time the power is three i'm still
going from one to two i'm going to
subtract n lots of the previous
i so that's 3 lots of i2
okay here comes the upper bound so it's
going to be 2 outside of log 2 cubed
take away i've done this enough times to
say oh i know what that's 0 because
there's going to be a log 1 term in
there right
so that's done there and then 3 lots of
and then you can see that i'm going to
get the previous i which i evaluated
right there
i think i need a bit more space
okay fantastic i'm so very close here
comes the last line 2 of log 2 cubed and
then how many of the squares do i have 6
of those log 2 squared watch that double
negative so it's plus 12 of just the log
2s and then i'm going to take away
6.
take a breath that's it
so
that's the result we needed to get for
part 2. i did promise i would show you
what would happen if instead of building
up from zero up to three what would
happen if you tried to climb down from
three down to zero totally doable as
well in fact it's actually fewer lines
of working however because the reason
why it's fewer lines of working is
because in each line you're doing more
so i'm not even going to finish it
because you know what the answer is but
let me just show you what it looks like
if i try to do this from i3 so i'm going
to say all right line 1
is going to be the integral from 1 to 2
of log x
all cubed dx and let's see how far we
can get before you start to realize what
this is becoming a mess
all right i go and i refer to
the recurrence relation right here so
i'm already jumping in at three i'm
jumping in from the top of the ladder
right i'm climbing down so therefore i'm
gonna say well this is going to be x
log x
cubed from one to two so you'll
recognize this we just did this right
and then i'm going to have to subtract
n lots of 3 i n minus 1. now
i don't know what i n minus 1 is because
i'm climbing down i don't know anything
right so i just have to say well what's
i2 in this case which i haven't
evaluated so i'm going to write in what
i2 is now by definition it's going to be
the integral from 1 to 2 of log x
or squared with respect to x okay
now at this point you're like this is
not this doesn't seem too bad mr willy
like i feel like i'm doing exactly the
same thing that i did before one more
line and then i think you're going to
see it okay
all right so i've got i've got this here
i better start expanding that right so
uh what am i going to get here comes the
lower bounds so it'll be 2 log 2 cubed
minus 1
log 1 also cubed that's done and then i
look at this bit and i'm like hm okay i
don't know how to integrate this but i
can climb down the next rung of the
ladder so i can have that minus 3 out
the front and then i can say well let's
just do this whole thing again right i'm
going to put even bigger brackets and
then i'm going to use the recurrence
relation another time for n equals 2. so
that's going to be take a breath x log x
squared
from 1 to 2
take away n lots of so this n is 2 and
then i'm integrating and i've climbed
down one step so oops from 1 to 2
and that's going to be to the power of 1
so i'll just i guess i'll just leave
that with respect to x and then i can
close my curly brace
okay
are you starting to see why this is a
the method that works if you can do your
algebra perfectly and your calculus
perfectly but you're you're sort of
asking to make errors okay let me
explain what i mean
we are doing a lot of things at once
right this is a recipe kind of for
disaster we are expanding this and sort
of evaluating this and at the same time
we are making this turn into something
much larger and i'm going to have to do
it again right you can see this is i1
i'm going to need to kind of one more
step to get to i0 so you can see this
line here is just getting longer and
longer and longer as i unfold each of
the reduction formulas and it gets you
know each each single integral turns
into
the two components that come from
integration by parts so it's getting
bigger and at the same time i'm also
trying to do all these other bits right
not to mention see this minus three that
applies here it applies to everything
inside the bracket so it applies to this
definite integral i'm about to evaluate
it also applies to this minus 2 so
that's going to be a plus 6 in the end
which you can see here you can see why
it does is supposed to be a plus 6 but
look you're just adding more minus signs
and you're nesting your brackets further
and further i've got curly braces for
goodness sake so this line here is going
to get worse whereas you could see as we
built up here even though there was
still more to consider i already
simplified i2 at this point i had it
down to its simplest form so all i had
to do was multiply it once by -3 and off
i went right and the same thing happened
further and further along i could
simplify as i went and i was only
considering i zero in this case i was
only considering i1 and so on
whereas here even though you absolutely
can do it and you of course get the same
solution you have to be so cautious
because it's easy for your errors to
creep in just because you're keeping
you're adding more and more things into
your brain so you have to be quite
cautious that's why this method is
probably less desirable and the students
who did it this way building from zero
up to three generally experienced much
more success